[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast
police in washington are trying to work
out what drove a man to ram his car into
police officers at the u.s capitol
building
killing one and injuring another the
security threat in washington had only
recently been lowered following the
january the sixth riots
the suspect identified as
twenty-five-year-old noah green was not
previously known to police he drove his
car into the two officers at a barricade
outside the u.s capitol building
police say that he then got out of the
vehicle and ran at them with a knife
before he was shot dead
the officer who survived is now said to
be in a stable condition
alex rossi reports from washington
the u.s capitol is still reeling from
this attack
a car careering into two police officers
before smashing
into the barricade a man then jumped out
brandishing a knife before he was shot
he later died from his
injuries the suspect has now been named
as 25 year old noah green from indiana
on his social media he described himself
as unemployed
and a follower of the nation of islam a
black nationalist
movement police are still trying to
establish the motive
but they do not believe at this early
stage that this was terrorism related
the investigation is ongoing from what
we can
see from video at this time i do not see
the suspect wrestling with a u.s capitol
police officer
but when he exited the vehicle the knife
was clearly
in his hand and he did start to run
toward the officers
this entrance is one of several
accessing the u.s capital complex
and it's primarily used by senators and
their staff
although congress is currently in recess
staff and journalists who were inside at
the time were warned to stay away from
windows
and seek cover these pictures filmed by
a bystander
show the immediate aftermath
security is still very tight here at the
capitol buildings the center
of the united states government now
investigators are still carrying out
their forensic work trying to understand
exactly what happened but what is
already clear
is that after the events of january the
6th
this has been another traumatic day for
the police
one of the police has now died from his
injuries and he's been named as william
evans a serving officer for 18 years
president joe biden has reacted
expressing his heartfelt condolences to
his family
and sending his gratitude to all those
who responded to the attack
i ask you to please keep the united
states capitol police family
in your thoughts and prayers at this
time it has been an extremely difficult
and challenging
year for us but we will get through this
and we do
appreciate the community support
washington dc has been on high alert for
the last few months
following this the storming of the
capitol building by donald trump
supporters
rallying to his false claims that the
presidential election was stolen
the security services warned that
further unrest could follow
in america's febrile political
environment
once again this is a city in mourning
coming to terms with another attack on
its center of power
alex rossi sky news washington dc
the medicines regulator has urged people
to continue taking the astrazeneca
coronavirus vaccine
despite revealing that seven people have
died from unusual blood clots in the uk
the medicines and healthcare products
regulatory agency confirmed that of the
18 million people who've had the jab
30 had blood clots afterwards lara
reporter hanisha sethi is in the
newsroom this morning with more on this
and
is it clear at this stage whether this
is just a coincidence or a side effect
of the vaccine
well at this stage there hasn't been any
evidence to suggest a causal link
between blood clotting
and the oxford astrazeneca vaccine and
let's take you through
some of the data that has been shared by
the medicines and regulatory
agency it says that by the 24th of march
18.1 million people were vaccinated
with the oxford astrazeneca jab in the
uk enough these people
30 developed a really unusual type of
blood clotting and of those
reported blood clots seven have sadly
died
but when put into perspective that
really is a small
number and it has to be weighed against
the actual threat of
catching coronavirus itself and the
complications that that could lead to
further down the line
but in some countries in europe they
have restricted the use of the oxford
astrazeneca jab
and particularly with the older age
group as a precautionary measure
but the chief executive of the mhra has
stressed that the benefits of taking the
vaccine
really do outweigh the risks and this is
the statement that they've released
they say that the benefits of the covert
19 vaccine astrazeneca in preventing
cover 19 infection
and its complications continue to
outweigh any risks
and they also go on to say that the
public should continue to get their
vaccine
when invited to do so and it's important
to note as well that the government have
stressed that the vaccination
is the most effective way to really not
just reduce deaths but also
prevent any serious illnesses that can
occur when taking the vaccine
but there are ongoing investigations
surrounding the blood clotting as a lot
of questions will be raised about this
but safety is of absolute paramount when
weighing the risks
and benefits of the vaccine and it is
something that healthcare regulatory
agencies take
very seriously asha thank you
the government has announced that
children will be able to visit their
grandparents in care homes in just over
a week's time
in many cases for the very first time in
a year
from the 12th of april care home
residents in england will be able to
receive
two indoor visitors in the latest easing
of covert restrictions and physical
correspondent rob
powell joins me now from westminster rob
this will come as welcome news to
many families and were we expecting this
announcement from the government
i think given almost all care home
residents have now had at least
one dose of the jab it was perhaps some
sort of easing was perhaps expected
i think there will be those who want
this to go faster though we've heard
some criticism about
care home residents not being allowed
out to go on trips and having to
self-isolate if they do go out
others may be mindful of what's happened
in the last 12 to 14 months
i'm worried about going any faster in
terms of this announcement today though
for the last month or so care home
residents
have been able to have one regular named
visitor who has to take a test before
they come inside
um has to wear ppe but is allowed some
contacts such as handholding
that will now be increased to two but
crucially
as well if those visitors are parents
they can bring
babies or very young children with them
which will mean
in some cases grandparents great
grandparents uh getting to meet
new arrivals new babies for the very
first time
i'm rob the commission on race and
ethnic disparities published their
report this week it has been hugely
criticized they've now
uh issued a response yeah the commission
publishing um quite a lengthy statement
quite a punchy statement late last night
which
in their own words they say they hope
will set the record
um straight essentially what they're
saying
is that a lot of the accusations around
their report downplaying the extent of
racism in the country
misrepresenting the history of slavery
they're pushing back against that
and saying that they acknowledge that
racism
does exist that it is a force in the uk
still but they also take aim in quite
vocal terms
at some people that have criticized them
and the report saying that they believe
robust debate has tipped over into
willful misrepresentation
let me read you part of what the
statement says it says the deeply
personal attacks on many of us by
politicians
and other public figures are
irresponsible and dangerous
for example one mp presented
commissioners as members of the kkk
robust debate we welcome but to depict
us as racism deniers slavery apologists
or worse
is unacceptable now the mp they're
referring to is labour's
um clive lewis who um after tweeting out
a picture that did have a reference to
the kkk and it said that
he was talking about structural racism
not necessarily referring
directly to the commissioners now this
is a strongly worded response
from the commission i don't think it
will necessarily settle
um this matter and there will be many
that are still deeply unhappy and deeply
critical at some of the conclusions from
this report
it will be interesting to see i think in
the coming weeks and months
whether the government takes forward any
of the many practical recommendations in
this report such as
extending school days such as more money
for the equalities and human rights
commission or dropping the bame
acronym whether any of those actually
make it into policy
or whether this report has now just
become so toxic
and ends up on a dusty shelf in
westminster along it should be said
with a lot of other reports of this
nature that have been published in the
past
dude rob thank you now to the
fifth day of one of america's most high
profile murder cases
a senior police officer has said the
level of force used to detain george
floyd was totally unnecessary
the arresting officer derek chauvin who
knelt on mr floyd's neck for more than
nine minutes before he died
has pleaded not guilty to murder and
manslaughter charges
our u.s correspondent sally lockwood has
the latest from minneapolis
the use of force against george floyd
was uncalled for
and totally unnecessary damning
testimony from a top
officer on derrick chavin's actions in
keeping his knee
on george floyd's neck have you ever
in all the years you've been working for
the minneapolis police department
been trained to kneel on the neck of
someone who is handcuffed behind their
back in a prone position
no i haven't is that if that were done
would that be considered force
absolutely what level of force might
that be
that would be the top tier the deadly
force why
because of the fact that
if if your knee is on a person's neck
that can kill him
as head of homicide lieutenant zimmerman
was deployed to the scene
after it emerged george floyd had died
the court had previously heard when
paramedics arrived
one believed george floyd was already
dead
and how derek shovin stayed on top of
him when the medic was trying to check
for a pulse
now critical evidence from a senior
officer
who says keeping a suspect in this
position is against police protocol
once you secure or handcuff a person
you need to get them out of the prone
position as soon as possible
because it restricts their breathing
after an intense and emotional week
in court the parting evidence for the
jury
from one of his own colleagues presents
a challenge for derek chauvin's defense
that he was simply doing what he'd been
trained to do
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis
nearly 80 percent of teachers feel their
job has negatively impacted their mental
health during the pandemic
and one in four have consulted a medical
professional about it
that's according to research from the
teachers union ahead of its annual
conference which starts today
joining me now is the general secretary
of the teachers union the nas uwt
dr patrick roach good morning to you um
80
that is an extremely high percentage of
teachers who feel that their mental
health has been
impacted yes it is uh
and um you know we're very concerned
about
um the continuing impact of
pressures around a workload
in schools uh issues around safety and
pupil behavior
but of course the pandemic has also
taken its toll
and around half of teachers are saying
that
their mental health has seriously
suffered
during the last 12 months and what sort
of help are they receiving
well of course i mean our members are
certainly turning to us to the nhwt
for support and assistance and of course
you know
we will liaise and make representations
to school and college employers
to see what can be done to support
individuals
but actually the issues are far more
systemic
in terms of the the nature of work that
teachers are being asked to do
um particularly during the pandemic
because schools uh
opened and closed and opened again uh
teachers were in class they were
providing
online uh learning they've had to cope
with last minute announcements uh from
the government
in terms of safety and in terms of
qualifications and awards
all of this has created mounting
pressure on
the profession and you know the
profession can't be expected to simply
soldier on
what have you made of the education
secretary's performance over the last
year
well uh it's tempting to uh to give an
off-the-cuff
answer to that but you know um at the
end of the day
government has a role to do and it has a
responsibility to take
uh to ensure that the entitlement of all
children to
high-quality education is in place gavin
williamson is coming to our conference
addressing our conference today and you
know teachers will want more than just
simply warm
words uh from uh mr williamson uh
they'll want to see
how he's setting out in terms of his
plans
addressing that mental health crisis for
teachers and indeed for pupils in
schools
addressing the workload concerns how
he's going to deal with
teachers anger about the pay freeze
which has been inflicted
on teachers after the service that they
provided um
through the last 12 months but you must
have a view on his performance over the
last 12 months
well i mean there are questions about
the performance of
the government in terms of its competent
handling of this pandemic we've seen
late guidance being produced
we've seen um multiple u-turns in
relation to
guidance to schools we've seen the
absence of
ppe equipment for for teachers um
you know teachers have got serious
concerns about
that so those examples has gavin
williamson been an effective
education secretary look i mean the
reality is that
uh we should never have been in a
position
um in which uh teachers felt unsupported
uh during the course of this pandemic
and
ultimately the minister has to take
responsibility
and you know ministers have to be held
to a camp that's what i would say on the
matter
um in recent days just want to bring you
uh bring the discussion around to a
story that we've seen much written about
and that stories of
sexual misconduct in schools with two
actually named in the telegraph today
accused of downplaying allegations of a
rape culture
what are you doing to address this
so-called culture
well i mean from the point of view the
nswt we are
extremely concerned about uh the report
um that we have seen the uh
testimonies from uh young people uh
on everyone's invited uh
it is serious concern to us uh that
those should be the experiences of any
child of any young person
uh in school or college um and
um you know we're absolutely uh
supportive of
uh a thorough investigation into
what's happened here so nspcc and ofsted
have got important work to do in that
regard and we will support them
in terms of doing that but you know it's
also
extremely important that we understand
um what the root causes are
of a culture within any school within
any school
system uh which where such practices
may take place it's vitally important
the teachers and support staff
know where to report concerns it's also
critically important that when concerns
are reported
that those concerns are acted upon and
acted upon
swiftly there should never be a culture
in
any school in any institution uh where
concerns about reputational damage take
precedence over the concerns about the
rights not only of children young people
who are subject to
such abhorrent behavior but the
experiences of teachers
as well who may also be subject to
unacceptable behaviour
in their workplace very quickly because
we're running out of time with the
badly grammar school we we know that uh
the teacher concerned is in hiding
uh fearing for his life and two other
teachers have been
suspended do you believe that this has
been handled appropriately
well it can never be appropriate for any
teacher
uh to face death threats uh intimidation
and abuse uh and to be forced into
hiding
uh because they're doing uh their job um
there's gotta be absolute leadership on
this issue right from the top
that includes the education secretary to
ensure that teachers can go about their
daily work
safe in the knowledge that they
have the confidence and backing of the
public in terms of the education of
children and young people
okay dr patrick roach thank you very
much for speaking to us this morning
ahead of the conference starting today
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with naz
and you're smiling but it's not to be
sunny
but well it is there oh not for southern
and eastern areas but
the vast majority of the uk and ireland
are going to have another fine day with
lots of sunshine
especially in the north and west where
it will feel rather warm but from easter
monday
everywhere is turning colder and wintry
as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking fine for today
and for tomorrow but from easter monday
onwards
we are going to get a cold arctic blast
developing across much of the uk and
ireland and there will be the risk of
some
wintry outbreaks so pretty much anywhere
let's take a look at today though and
there's lots of sunshine out there this
morning it's a chilly start
frosty isolated patches of mist and fog
across northern and western areas
temperatures generally starting below
freezing particularly across western
parts of scotland
meanwhile for central southern and
eastern areas it's less cold and less
frosty but it's cloudier
going into this afternoon we will keep
quite a bit of the cloud across southern
and eastern areas so as a result
under the cloud cover and the uh
northeasterly winds it will feel quite
cool there but elsewhere lots of
sunshine best in the north and west
will feel rather warm
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning you're watching sky news
breakfast our top stories this morning
investigators are exploring possible
motives after a police officer was
killed and another injured
at the u.s capitol building when a man
drove his car into the barrier the
suspect was killed
at the scene children will be able to
visit grandparents in care homes in
england from the 12th of april
as residents are to be able to receive
two indoor
visitors in the latest easing of covid
restrictions
the medicines regulators urge people to
still come forward for a covered vaccine
when
invited after it confirmed seven people
have died from
blood clots after taking the astrazeneca
jam
at a speech at the teaching unions
conference later today
labour will claim that a decade of poor
decisions by the government
has let children down and that the
future of every child must be
prioritized as the uk
emerges from the pandemic ladies shadow
education secretary kate green joins me
now and how have children been let down
what we've seen over the last 10 years
is immense pressure on school budgets
uh and that they are now in real terms
worse off than they were
10 years ago and the pandemic has
exacerbated the pressures that schools
are facing
so we're in a situation where children
have significantly
suffered disruption to their learning
over the past year the
funding that schools should receive for
the most disadvantaged children
has um been effectively cut by the way
that the government has failed properly
to count those children
and schools have had to dip into budgets
that they should have been using for
teaching to meet costs of making their
premises covered secure social
distancing and so on
so all of this is putting a great deal
of pressure on schools at a time when of
course children need
additional support as they come back to
school
and have lost learning to make up and of
course
also a lot of attention needing to be
paid to their social and emotional
well-being
how would you solve the problems as you
outline them is it simply a case of
throwing money at them
well it's not throwing money at schools
it's investing in in schools and in
children and making sure that
the qualified trained teachers are there
to support their learning
and their well-being so there are some
obvious short-term
needs that schools have to to make sure
they've got the resources
uh to educate every child and and help
them recover their lost learning
uh but we need a long-term investment in
our schools and in our teaching
profession
uh we need to make sure teachers are
properly paid as things stands they're
facing a paid freeze this year
when they've been working flat out and
getting children learning through the
pandemic
we need proper progression and
development opportunities for teachers
and we need to make sure that every
child has the resources they need to
learn
both in school and for home learning uh
when they're doing homework or as we've
seen during the pandemic if they have to
be at home for a time
making sure they've got the digital
resources to learn effectively
in and out of the classroom these are
all things that the government
are saying should be uh work towards as
well
um with the fact that children have been
returning to school
uh we've seen that there hasn't really
been a a rise or a spike in in cases
of covid um would you like to take this
opportunity to congratulate
gavin williamson on the successful
return to school of students
i'm very pleased that students are back
in school and that as you say
we seem to be coping well now as the
vaccination programme is rolling out
with managing
the risk of the spread of infection but
i'm certainly not congratulating gavin
williamson
after a year in which we've seen an
exams debacle
we've seen schools being told to open
and close and open and closed children
sent home repeatedly a massive
disruption to their learning
laptops still not fully delivered as
promised to children who need to learn
at home
and i think that really if you ask
parents what they think of gavin
williamson's performance over the last
12 months they are deeply dissatisfied
and rightly so
how would you fix the problems that
we've seen emerging of misogyny and
sexual misconduct and this morning we
read
a couple of schools that been accused of
a culture
of rape this is a really
important question and it's not
something that's new to us
the women in equalities committee in
parliament was warning of this
five years ago in a report that the
government appears pretty well to have
disregarded up until now
we have to have zero tolerance of sexual
harassment misogyny
um and abuse in in school we need to
make sure that teachers are trained and
equipped to
deal with it when it's disclosed to them
teachers particularly say that
it can be very difficult if a young girl
doesn't want action taken
and yet they you know it's obvious that
we can't tolerate abuse and harassment
in school they they want the training to
equip them
uh to deal with that and we need a real
uh strategy action for for stamping out
this kind of horrific abuse in school
but it's not of course just in school
it's in wider society
and i think we've all seen with absolute
horror um the way in which violence
against women and girls is still
prevalent uh and we need a really
comprehensive approach to tackling that
from our criminal justice system our
education system
and from as collectively as a kate green
shadow education sanctuary thank you for
speaking to us this morning
thank you good morning we are going to
see a lot of fine and dry weather for
today
and for tomorrow but from easter monday
onwards it is set to turn a lot colder
with fairly widespread wintry showers
expected as well but back to today
there's lots of sunshine out there this
morning it's a mainly dry start as well
particularly across the northern and
western parts it's a
sunny morning but frosty and chilly with
some isolated fog patches less cold over
central southern eastern areas but
that's because there's a fair amount of
a cloud
going into this afternoon the best of
the sunshine continues across northern
and western parts it will actually feel
fairly warm
in the sunshine as well across these
areas but again
we hold on to quite a bit of cloud
across southern and eastern parts of
england in particular
so it will feel cooler under the
cloudier zones there central parts
parts of the midlands as well will
brighten up the later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
you're watching sky news breakfast still
to come and take a look
at what's making the front pages with
maria logan mclean
a politics editor of the magazine galdem
and journalist and author ella whelan
[Music]
back with us this morning to review the
papers
mclean the politics editor of the
magazine galdem and journalist and
author
ella whelan welcome back to both of you
let's start with you first of all moya
and
the times and uh this story about a
police marksman that's facing misconduct
charges tell us about this story yes so
this is on page five the times today and
it's about
a police marksman who is kept anonymous
uh but he shot and killed jermaine
barker jermaine baker in 2015 um when
baker attempted to
attack a police fan so
they've now this marksman has now been
appointed a firearms trainer despite
facing disciplinary action for gross
misconduct
and i think an appeal that found that
there was no
uh reasonable threat to life that
warranted
the action that was taken and that
resulted in the killing
of jermaine baker the story also
mentions the case of
matt horn an a deputy assistant
commissioner who has paid
a hundred and fifty thousand pounds a
year
um who oversaw anti-corruption
investigations and
has now been put in charge of something
called futures work at the met
despite being found guilty of three
charges of misconduct
for bullying officers i think the story
is interesting because it seems to show
more of this insular brushing under the
rug culture within the police
that has led to such widespread mistrust
for example
last week we had the report on the
clapham common vigil which found that
police force was seen as reasonable
according to
that committee but a whistleblower has
recently said that
this report was skewed to back police
and alleges it's broken the civil
service code
uh it fits also into the pattern that we
saw about reports about
sex abuse allegations within the police
that were majority
um no disciplinary action was taken and
officers were allowed to continue
serving which i think was reported
in the independent so this when reports
like this come out you have to
wonder why are the police not choosing
to take
action do they not realize the impact
that these sort of incidents have
you know if an officer who can take part
in a fatal shooting
can then be appointed a firearms trainer
to pass on
that sort of approach and knowledge to
other officers there is a deeper
cultural problem
going on and you have to say when will
they actually stand back and think hmm
maybe we should address this
ella take us to the telegraph and
obviously this will come as welcome news
to to many families and this is the fact
that now grandchildren
will be able to to make visits to care
homes and some of them
will not have even seen their their
grandchildren some of them born
during the pandemic yes this is on the
front page of the telegraph and actually
across all of the papers um as you say a
welcome bit of news the fact that
not only just that grandchildren
children will be able to come and visit
their
grandparents in care homes but that the
limit on the number of people who can
make a visit will move from
one to two so small steps the visitors
will still have to
have a negative corona virus test they
will still have to be
dressed up in the full ppe there are
still things like a ban on hugging
so this is certainly not a return to
normality but it is a step in the right
direction
important thing about this story however
which the telegraph picks up on
is that the this is uh guidance that the
government is releasing so the guidance
is going to change to
uh to extend it to two people what
some groups who are campaigning around
uh getting
looser restrictions around care home
residents and allowing more people to go
and visit them are saying
in particular campaign group called
rights for residents is that it's all
very well the government giving guidance
on this but the problem is that man the
telegraph mentions this
many care homes will choose not to take
that guidance either because it's too
difficult
because they are wanting to maintain for
various reasons a level of kind of
proportionate principle that they don't
want to facilitate
more visitors coming in um or just that
or that they won't
they think it's not the right thing to
do at the moment and that's where the
problem lies that's where you end up
getting a bit of a postcode lottery
which means that
the more well-off and often private care
homes where people are paying a lot of
money
have the facilities to allow to make
arrangements to allow more residents to
come in
and the poorer ones or the ones that are
less well run the less with quality ones
people are remaining under restrictions
staying at home not being allowed
not being allowed any visitors and
that's a that's a really big problem
because one of the things we know about
the pandemic and the restrictions in
particular when it comes to care home
residents
is that a lot of people not all but a
lot of residents in care homes will be
suffering from things like dementia
and starvation of social contact is what
really accelerates those kinds of
um conditions and diseases and there
have been heartbreaking stories of
people deteriorating throughout the last
year
which could have been prevented from
just some one-on-one time with their
loved ones
so really the emphasis has to be on not
just allowing one person in a
few grandchildren in dressed up in ppe
but now that 60
of adults around about have been
vaccinated and everyone in a care home
almost everyone has
had at least one dose of the vaccine
what more can the government be doing
to not just encourage but actually
mandate i think that care homes should
facilitate as many visitors
as possible within sensible restrictions
yeah and we hope that the the residents
can benefit because as we you say we can
see how they've
deteriorated through the pandemic to
uh the male moyer and who's saying that
jeremy corbyn should be apologized for
that labour should apologize for jeremy
corbyn who's telling us that
jeremy corbyn the specter that haunts
labor um
so this is page 36 the daily mail and a
key ally of sir kiyostama has warned
that labour must say sorry about jeremy
corbyn
it's not enough he has had the whip
removed they must stay sorry too
um i think the story is quite
interesting because the the source is
suggesting
and they're apparently very close a
shadow cabinet source
says that labour has to demonstrate it's
sorry for imposing corbyn in order to
win back
the red wall however you have to wonder
why this is being briefed now
as polls show stammers got sliding
approval
and a poll this week in that key red
wall area by um
jay johnson's company found the
conservatives were ahead by a point
um with starmer himself seen as labour's
biggest weakness and people saying that
they didn't know what he stood for
i don't think jeremy corbyn was
mentioned because i i just don't know
what more
kierstama can take in terms of action
towards jeremy corbyn as he has removed
the whip
um it seems like that is not enough for
some people within the shadow cabinet
um although perhaps they should look
closer to home to the problems this
seems to be like a key
sort of politicking story placed in the
mail
by this source who wishes to push them
even further
but i think it will take a bit more than
saying sorry for jeremy corbyn at this
stage
ella something completely different in
the sun uh tell us why our online
ad ban will batter our chippies i see
what they did there
well this is a but there's a column by
greg wallace and who many will know from
masterchef
um but it's just an interesting story
because i know lots of us will have the
one thing that we can't have indulged in
across the pa
throughout the pandemic is takeaways and
it's actually been a lifeline for many
restaurants and
eateries to be able to provide that
service and what greg wallace is talking
about is the fact that the
plans for the new government advan to
com
as the government describes it to combat
obesity
will essentially [ __ ] those same
restaurants and more in particular he
picks up on the fact that it seems to
always be
the kind of food that working-class
people enjoy whether it be fish and
chips or whatever rather than the
more fattening higher end of the scale
of more middle class
restaurants and what they put out but
the really important thing he puts here
that greg wallace talks about is the
fact that
there's very few people left on this
earth that order from a chippy
and think that that's a healthy meal i
mean he says you know what you know what
you're getting when you watch it frying
in the fat you know
understand that this is an unhealthy
meal you understand that it's a treat so
what he's really
championing is a sensible you know
sentiments of people to be able to make
decisions and government ad ban really
undermines this